У радіоефірі - лише білоруські станції. В телеефірі - теж переважно білоруське телебачення.
Але це не Білорусь. А Україна.
Село Переброди на Рівненщині розташоване прямісінько на українсько-білоруському кордоні.
Так, як в Івано-Франківську з мадярами, так ми з білорусами.
Тут у Перебродах українців чистих немає, ні єдиного.
Тут білоруси всі, корінні білоруси. Евсович, Чмуневич і пішло  на "Ч" всі прізвища.
60-річний Петро доглядає за старенькою Олександрою Євсович. Їй - 82 роки.
Жінка народилася тут за рік до того, як у минулому сторіччі Переброди разом з Дубровицьким районом
відійшли від Польщі до УРСР. Олександра вважає себе більше українкою, ніж білорускою,
і каже, що усе село спілкується специфічною мовою. Не українською і не білоруською, а "перебродською".
Кажуть "баяли". Не кажуть "говорили".
Не кажуть "у тебе", а кажуть "у цебе". Цебе. ЦЕе ніби-то і "тябе" і таке- "цабе". І українець нібито…
І білорус.
У бабці Олександри є дві надійні подружки. Надія та Анастасія.
Вони - членкині місцевого фольклорного гурту "Берегиня",
який часто виступав і на Західний Україні, і в Білорусі.
Бабусі жаліються, що через коронавірус вже сім місяців не можуть
відвідати своїх родичів в сусідніх селищах республіки Білорусь.
Принаймні бабці, як і кожна місцева родина, мають білоруську телефонну картку,
а завдяки сильному сигналу з-за кордону можуть розмовляти з родичами,
не користуючись роумінгом.
Тож кажуть, що знають про актуальні події в республіці Білорусь з першоджерел
- не тільки з білоруського телебачення, а й від родичів.
Жіноцтво дуже переймається за своїх рідних там.
Війна. Те, що в нас на Донбасі, там! Може бути таке.
Лукашенко казав, що я не упущу свою країну.
Вони ж борються з цим президентом. Не хочуть його.
Молодь! А такі, як ми - ні.
За кілометр звідси городами і за п’ять кілометрів дорогою крізь ліси -
український прикордонний пункт пропуску.
Навпроти - білоруський пункт пропуску "Ольмани".
Вони були створені приблизно 20 років тому задля спрощення перетину кордону
мешканцями прикордонних поселень у вихідні та святкові дні.
До пандемії цією можливістю користувалися близько двох десятків людей.
Наразі пункти пропуску закриті.
Прикордонники час від часу затримують місцевих,
які попри заборону хочуть відвідати родичів чи збирають в лісі гриби та ягоди.
Влітку при спробі перетнути державний кордон затримали жінку.
Просто вона громадянка Білорусі і була тут законно, хотіла вийти через ліс.
Чи відкриються прикордонні пункти пропуску після пандемії - під питанням.
Відносини Києва та Мінська після президентських виборів
та придушення мирних протестів в Білорусі суттєво погіршилися.
МЗС України навіть призупинило усі дипломатичні відносини до стабілізації ситуації.
А Олександр Лукашенко, своєю чергою, привів війська в бойову готовність.
Напруга по той бік реально відчутна, кажуть українські прикордонники.
Так, ми спостерігаємо, з того боку збільшена кількість прикордонних нарядів.
Зі своєї сторони ми вживаємо відповідні заходи щодо недопущення
безконтрольного перетину держкордону та іншої протиправної діяльності.
Українські прикордонники несуть службу в посиленому режимі.
Напроти Перебродів, на білоруському боці, час від часу проходять військові навчання.
Зміцнення відносин Олександра Лукашенка з Кремлем
на тлі охолодження відносин з офіційним Києвом в Миляцькій ОТГ,
куди входить село Переброди, вважають потенційною загрозою.
Боятися - це таке… В нас тут недалеко є військовий полігон в Мерлінці,
то ми знаємо, навчання проходить. Ми знаємо, що воно таке є.
Навіть  один з одним спілкуємося, знаємо, що в будь-який момент танки можуть бути тут.
Готові до того… стараємося, щоб не допустити… щоб паніки цієї щоб не було.
Українсько-білоруський кордон протяжністю майже тисяча кілометрів
проходить через важкодоступні ліси і болота.
Цей напрямок, на думку експосла України в Білорусі Романа Безсмертного, найменш захищений.
На території Білорусі є три російські військові бази. Не дві, а три.
Три з минулої осені. Загальна кількість військових сягає майже 15 000
прекрасно  підготовлених представників Збройних сил  РФ.
Тому, це треба розуміти. Це найслабше місце в  безпеці і обороні України,
тому що всі 1000 км кордону фактично фортифікаційними спорудами не забезпечені,
бойовими одиницями не забезпечені.
Більше того, з 12 -ти переходів лише три врегульовані і облаштовані.
Решта - це більше лісові дороги.
Як повідомила DW пресслужба МЗС, план демаркації українсько-білоруського кордону
узгоджується обома країнами щорічно,
визначені місця встановлення прикордонних знаків на вісімдесяти відсотках кордону.
Завершити демаркацію заплановано на 2026 рік.
Прикордонники в Перебродах показують DW, що робота з облаштування кордону,
встановлення фортифікаційних споруд та демаркації  поступово ведеться.
Недемаркований кордон означає, що на місцевості він не позначений прикордонними знаками.
Як такий кордон є , існує. Він закріплений знов-таки міжнародними договорами,
міжурядовими договорами.
Єдине, що не в повній мірі він позначений на місцевості.
Але робота на даний момент ведеться.
У Перебродах у можливість військової загрози з боку Білорусі геть не вірять.
Що війною підуть на Україну?! Це фантазія, я вам скажу. Це повний абсурд.
Що білоруси сюди війною підуть!
Там успокоїться. Сподіваюсь. Якщо вони Лукашенка проженуть, то програють.
То буде, як в нас, а то і гірше. Так є якась стабільність.
Я особисто прихильник того, щоб в нас була співпраця з Білоруссю.
А так знаю, як бачу в інтернеті, то пишуть різне.
Що Білорусь співпрацює з Росією, а в нас проблема на Сході.
А ми тут ближче до Білорусі. Нам би хотілося, щоб була робота.
У Перебродах працювати ніде. Деякі селяни наймаються до нелегальних бурштинокопачів
- у лісах на Рівненщині їх багато.
Інші - живуть з городів і з заробітків у Білорусі.
Влітку і восени тут гаряча пора. Селяни масово купують ліцензії на збір ягід
на білоруській території і непогано заробляють на журавлині, брусниці, чорниці.
Також наймаються на сезонні роботи в ті ж білоруські радгоспи,
де теж платять непогано, розповідають місцеві.
Рік тому багато молоді їздили – на огірки , на парники.
Утім, з огляду не нестабільність в Білорусі, яка може затягнутися,
селяни почали потроху освоювати і ринок підробітків в ЄС.
Водночас люди сподіваються, що Україна і Білорусь збережуть добрі відносини,
адже економіка прикордонних районів обох країн тісно пов’язана.
За сім місяців карантину торгові центри і ринки в райцентрах Рівненщини
вже відчули негативні наслідки через брак клієнтів з Білорусі,
які раніше приїжджали сюди кожні вихідні.